profitons de la situation pour vous
présenter deux 4 4 du marché français la
Lada Niva et la Citroën Méhari avec
Claude au volant de la Niva et Bernard à
celui de la Méhari l’aniva fabriqué en
URSS 1600 cm³ 9 chevaux présenté ici
dans son modèle luxe on aurait un peu
tendance si on s'en sert davantage sur
la route à dire c'est un véhicule qui
consomme mais si on la compare à tout
autre véhicule tout-terrain et c'est
réellement avec une souterrain parce que
c'est quatre roues motrices avec
réducteur et blocage de différentiel
interpont ça reste un véhicule qui
consomme relativement peu la Méhari
version 4 roues motrices trois chevaux
fiscaux moteur 602 cm3 quelles sont ses
qualités les qualités et les qualités et
les qualités surtout des qualités de
franchissement les relativement en bas
c'est bien importantes et puis elle a
des réducteurs il y a un blocage
de différentiel alors là non pas
interpont mais sur les rousses qui comme
une adhérence complémentaire je dirais
que c'est une bonne mécanique quand on
reste c'est pas léger quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'anniv va en revanche autorise des
déplacements sur route Claude oui à
reste tout de même une bonne routière et
une voiture qui est
qui est vraiment dans le créneau actuel
c'est à dire ça fait la voiture verte
d'ailleurs ça va vous permettre de vous
déplacer sur route comme la voiture de
tous les jours je ne sera pas d'autres
marques enfin il y a 5 ou autre voiture
gros avantage également sur la neige le
tout adhérence et quelque chose de
fabuleux sur la neige ça vous permet une
chose c'est de ne pas clouter ce qui est
quand même un ennui en moins descendre
pour clouter une voiture l'hiver c'est
très désagréable plus de ça c'est froid
et bien sûr les gens qui se retrouvent
cultivateurs ou voir vétérinaire ou
autre chose ça ouvre quand même pas mal
de portes
[Musique]
bon là c'est à peu près le cas extrême
là avec avec des voitures à grandement
comme ça et qui tiennent pas mal mais là
il y a encore encore de la marge on peut
encore l'envoyer puis bon bah elle est
comme ça autant profiter et voir un peu
comment on sait faire là-dessus ce qu'il
a différencie des autres voitures c'est
là l'attraction arrière là tu as tu as
un pont qui te renvoie deux cardans bon
ben on se rend bien compte qu'elle est
motrice sur les sur les quatre roues et
là bah on va la descendre maintenant il
y a pas de problème
ce n'est pas un véhicule qui a été fait
conçu pour porter une charge importante
c'est essentiellement un véhicule de bon
le qualifier de liaison
avec avec pendant bon bah des limites en
gardant au sol entre autres elle est
relativement basse des limites en
diamètre de roues
il y a également des problèmes de pneu
actuellement mais qui vont être résolus
semble-t-il ça reste assez
indéfinissable c'est un véhicule on sait
pas trop le classer en fait mais avec un
pouvoir de franchissement et surtout une
tenue en deux verres du fait de ce
faible centre de gravité extraordinaire
limité malgré mais ce qui n'est pas
limité en revanche c'est le prix ah
alors c'est c'est là je crois ou la
Méhari blesse a du mal a du mal à
franchir le pas par rapport à ses
concert et plus particulièrement à la à
la la daniva c'est qu'elle fait quand
même plus de 50 000 francs
avec aussi des accessoires de bâches une
position de volant et un pédalier pas
toujours évident
[Musique]